l'école secondaire de rochebelle une
école publique à québec en fait bien des
jaloux début de l'année 2010 est le
ministre de l'éducation a inauguré ici
le tout nouveau complexe sportif de 15
millions de dollars
une annonce politique parmi tant
d'autres direz vous peut-être pas je
suis ici l inauguration communiste de
l'éducation c'était plutôt un signal que
le gouvernement couillard voulait lancer
le signal que les élèves figurer dans sa
liste des priorités
après deux ans de compressions majeures
de nombreuses tentatives pour réformer
les structures et après le passage de
quatre ministres en quatre ans je il
beauduc du clan sous serment que je
remplirai les devoirs de ma charge et
les prières pour d'abord son choix
semences ministre de la santé yves
bolduc pour menu une telle coopération
au ministère de l'éducation amputation
des budgets et des directions régionales
des ministères même les commissions
scolaires sont susceptibles de coiffure
history le gouvernement procéder à des
compressions financières d'urgence pour
atteindre le déficit zéro
urpo d'atteinte des services directs aux
élèves terminent et l'achat de nouveaux
livres décideront des commissions
scolaires confrontés aux restrictions
budgétaires
aucun enfant nomura déclare yves bolduc
en entrevue au journal le devoir
un enfant a jamais assez de lits c'était
une déclaration très malhabile jeter
aucun cachet des livres très
régulièrement il bolduc ne sera pas sa
première déclaration maladie rappelez
vous l'histoire de cette adolescente
fouillée à nu dans une école secondaire
de neufchâtel parce qu'elle était
soupçonné de vendre de la drogue
il est permis de faire des fouilles à nu
une seule condition il faut que ce soit
très respectueux époque escient de
fouilles à nu dans nos écoles sauf dans
les cas extrêmes justifiée par les
forces policières
ce n'est pas tout à ces deux bévues qui
ont fait la manchette ajouté ceci j'ai
toujours agi de bonne foi
yves bolduc avait reçu une prime
controversée de 215 milles dollars à
titre de médecin omnipraticien pour
avoir pris des patients à sa charge
pendant qu'il était député de
l'opposition
j'ai pris la décision personnelle de
retourner en pratique médicale si cette
émission n'a surpris personne
j'appelle monsieur françois blé jeu
françois blé des classes ou sûrement son
successeur le ministre françois blé ne
l'a pas tellement est plus facile
d'abord le grand ménage à l'éducation ne
rapporte pas autant qu'espéré
mon prédécesseur je pense a estimé
qu'ils avaient peut-être des des
économies à faire mais il n'y en a pas
la réduction de la bureaucratie que les
libéraux avaient promises en éducation
génère des économies deux fois moins
importante que prévu changer les choses
le gouvernement maintient que les
services aux élèves ne sont pas touchés
ce qui est faux rétorque que des parents
d'enfants autistes ou en difficulté
d'apprentissage des classes ont été
fermées en raison des compressions
budgétaires parents ces professeurs le
dénonce
en formant des chaîne humaine autour des
écoles
[Musique]
tandis que des manifestants saccagent
pavillon de l'uqam en pleine nuit la
menace d'une autre grève étudiante place
j'ai pas en injectant des sommes
massives d'argent dans les réseaux qu'on
obtient des résultats nécessairement
meilleur le gouvernement couillard
persiste à croire qu'il faut modifier la
structure du réseau de l'éducation
mais ne parle plus de la fusion des
commissions scolaires à laquelle jongler
yves bolduc françois blin songe plutôt à
abolir les élections scolaires et ainsi
remplacer les commissaires un jour ce
sont un peu comme une tonne de briques
nous devons donner un rôle accru aux
parents
l'abolition des élections scolaires ne
se concrétisera jamais françois blé est
remplacé par pierre moreau qui doit se
retirer après 25 jours seulement pour
des raisons de santé
et c'est finalement sébastien proulx qui
sera nommé à la tête du ministère
névralgique mais il partagera la tâche
avec hélène david qui s'occupera de
l'enseignement supérieur s'attaquer aux
structures et elle mauvaise idée
reconnaît premier ministre pour nous
concentrer d'abord et avant tout sur la
réussite éducative de nos élèves de nos
enfants s'ensuit alors un
réinvestissement massif 1,8 milliard de
dollars sur cinq ans pour procéder à
7200 embauche il travaille qu'on a
affaire là c'est dire aux commissions
scolaires maintenant vous pouvez
embauché il ya pas de frein à l'embauché
ajoute des ressources supplémentaires
fini les écoles en décrépitude promet le
ministre les investissements historiques
de plus de 2.3 milliards de dollars
seront réalisés à travers la province au
cours de l'année 2018 2019
durant son budget de l'année 2018 le
gouvernement promet une croissance des
dépenses en éducation de 5%
tout un contraste avec le maigre 0,2
pour cent d'augmentation de l'année 2015
cdppt on se demande à quoi ça sert avec
kylie budgétaire déjà qui se demande mme
x association avec sa politique de
cette indicative sébastien proulx veut
entre autres augmenter le taux de
diplomation encourager l'utilisation des
nouvelles technologies et détecter plus
facilement les difficultés
d'apprentissage il se donne douze ans on
parvenir aux résultats escomptés
[Musique]